pink is set to receive the michael
jackson video vanguard award at the 2017
mtv video music awards on sunday i'm
very lucky which recognizes her for her
impact on music pop culture fashion and
philanthropy now we're counting down
seven reasons why she's the perfect pick
for the high honor
she has been in the biz for 17 years has
had four number one singles on the
billboard hot 100 chart and 15 of her
songs have made the top 10.
she's a triple threat singer
[Music]
[Music]
and actress
[Music]
the 37 year old has already won six moon
men including video of the year for lady
marmalade
[Music]
best pop video for stupid girls
and best female video for get the party
started
[Music]
she brings her a game to live
performances which often includes some
pretty impressive acrobatics
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
pink is big on giving back supporting
charities like the make-a-wish
foundation autism speaks human rights
campaign and no kid hungry oh and did we
mention she's also an ambassador for
unicef
pink has three grammys hashtag no big
deal
and she isn't afraid to cross genres
even dipping into the country scene with
a kenny chesney collaboration
[Music]
their song setting the world on fire
earned her an 18th grammy nom in 2017.
congrats pink you deserve it
[Music]